breaking news from uh kate mccann about
another departure from the cabinet yeah
we're just looking at a tweet i'm
looking at a tweet here from robert
jenwick the secretary of state for
housing communities and local government
he's posted that in the last minute
saying it's been a huge privilege to
serve as secretary of state thank you to
everyone at the department for their
hard work dedication and friendship i'm
deeply proud of all we achieved i will
continue to support the prime minister
and the government
in every way i can now that's very
similar to the gavin williamson tweet
that we talked about earlier on again a
suggestion that he's been removed from
that job but not given another one
i will continue to support the prime
minister and the government in every way
i can is an indication that he doesn't
have a job formally in government
anymore at all again another big name
another big change and while we're
talking about all of this remember we
said that dominic robb went in to the
house of commons we believe
we understand that he went in to see the
prime minister boris johnson but we've
not yet heard anything about what
happened in that meeting it's been quite
a while now you know there are some who
would say
is that because the prime minister is in
there talking to him potentially about
another job you know we've talked in the
past about when some ministers say they
don't want to move they may well just
refuse all together potentially these
messages that we're seeing on twitter
robert jeremy and gavin williamson are
also ministers who've been offered
something else but have just flat out
refused it and that's why we're seeing
this kind of wording women and we do
know dominick roberts is
with the prime minister at the moment
and the prime minister we think
in westminster in parliament still we
understand so yes there was some
speculation that he might be back in
downing street but my understanding is
he's very much still in the house of
commons we haven't heard anything yet
from dominic grubb or any of those
around him about what's happened as a
result of that meeting so we can only
assume that he is still talking to boris
johnson the big question is a
conversation that long usually suggests
that somebody's maybe been offered a job
maybe they don't want to take it maybe
they're having a conversation about
whether there are any alternative
options this is all speculation right
now we are not in the room those two men
potentially are we'll of course bring
everything to you as soon as we have